We’re in Thailand b*****s!
Amazing!
Pepsi, I might
not be leaving.
I might stay forever.
Here's to all of
you fabulous ladies.
Woo!
-Ooh! Ooh! Ooh!
You know the sounds.
Why?
This is probably why
Gizelle is single.
Ooh! Ooh! Ooh!
No man wants to
have sex with that.
My intention for this trip?
That I keep all of my edges.
Hallelujah!
What is that big ol’ thing?
It looks like a penis.
Thank you.
This is a food orgasm.
It came on my face.
I wasn't expecting it.
Who going to
be my porn star?
I'm in.
Ooh!
Ahh!
Oh, yeah.
Lift that leg.
They were massaging
your vagina?
They were trying to.
I want my money back,
because ain’t
nobody touched mine.
Ha ha ha ha!
I mean, it's
eight housewives
in a foreign country,
what could go wrong?
Heather, you
talked about
your relationship
with Whitney.
So, like, is there
an issue or not?
You don’t like me,
I don’t like you.
Cool.
Leah, bye.
Porsha, bye.
Y’all became friends,
and 2 minutes later,
you and her
husband was dating.
You stole somebody's man.
Jen Shah.
You knew she was lying.
She either lied to me
five minutes before she
went into the courtroom,
or she lied to the judge.
You think you
were my friend
when you told everyone
I have a fake marriage?
You know what?
You f*****g need
to get on pills.
Your brain is like, fried.
You brought a statement
from that raggedy a** h**!
Because you’re acting
like I didn’t lie for you!
And I did!
I don’t owe you anything
for you to be loyal to me
as my f*****g cousin!
You’re shouting.
You fight.
Two minute?
Hey, hey hey!
Give me a hug!
That is fake.
What if, like,
one of the women
tries to frame me...
She's accusing us of larceny.
Hi, suspect number one!
Hi, green h**!
...and, like, gets
drugs from someone,
and puts it in my bag?
You wanted
me to go to jail!
Everyone’s looking at you.
You was tryin’
to set me up!
Haven’t you ever
seen that movie
with Claire Danes?
Brokedown Palace!
Keep breathing.
Don’t lift my legs,
I am not wearing underwear.
This is real?
Not TV?
This is real.
You guys just
gave me my period.
Thank you, does
anybody have a tampon?
Ay Dios mío﻿.
Who gets a period anymore?
That’s so 1980.